dimension is when you look at direct
variation these are equations in this
form y equals K times X sometimes we'll
write them y equals a times X but this K
value or a value is what they call the
constant of variation it's what relates
the two variables now with inverse
variation these are equations that are
in the form y equals a divided by ax or
y equals K divided by ax depending on
what letter your book or your class your
teacher uses to denote the constant of
variation but the thing to notice here
is that the ax here is in the numerator
and with inverse variation the X here is
in the denominator now what we're going
to do is we're going to rearrange the
equation to solve for the constant of
variation so let's just work with the a
here so if we solve for a we're going to
divide both sides by ax and so you can
see that a equals Y divided by X what
this means is that if we take all the Y
values divided by the X values and we
get the same a value each time the same
constant that tells us that this is
direct variation and it's going to be y
equals a times X okay now here if we
solve for a constant of variation let's
just use this one up here y equals a
divided by X if we multiply both sides
by ax you can see that a is going to
equal x times y so if we multiply the X
and y values together and we keep
getting the same a value then that tells
us that it's inverse variation so let's
see if I can show you what I mean in
these two examples so first thing we're
going to do here is let's see if we
multiply if we multiply the X and Y's
together you see how we get 3 12 3 times
9 is 27 4 times 12 is 48 we're not
getting the same quantity each time so
that tells us that it's not going to be
an inverse variation equation
let's try dividing so we're going to
take Y divided by X so 3 divided by 1 is
3 6 divided by 2 is 3 9 divided by 3 is
3 12 divided by 4 is 3 we're getting the
same a value or constant of variation so
that tells us that's direct variation
and that number that we were getting
when we divide each time is our constant
of variation that's 3 so you can see
that our formula is going to be y equals
3 times X now if you're not convinced go
ahead and pick some of the values for X
and see if you get the Y values so if X
is 4 3 times 4 is 12
yep if X is 3 e 3 times 3 is 9 yep so
you can verify it that way and you can
see it fits that form of the director
variation okay now let's go to the next
one here let's see if we divide the Y's
by the X's like we did over here twelve
divided by one is 12
four divided by three is one point three
repeating two divided by six is one
third and one twelve we're not getting
the same constant each time so that
tells us what that tells us that it's
not direct variation let's try
multiplying 1 times 12 is 12 3 times 4
is 12 12 12 okay so that tells us okay
this is an inverse variation equation
and our constant of variation is going
to be 12 y equals 12 divided by X if
you're not sure or not convinced go
ahead and test it out so all if we put 6
in for X 12 divided by 6
yep that gives us our Y value of 2